استعدوا فالحرب ستبدا بعد ساعات قليله
هكذا قالها حلفاء الغرب في افريقيا انقلاب
في القاره السمراء قد يؤدي الى حرب عالميه
العم سام واحفاد لوسي يعلنونها النيجر
مساله حياه او موت سنستعيدها حتى وان
بذلنا دماءنا من اجلها والدب الروسي يرد
اذا تهورتم فانتم الجانون على انفسكم سنرد
الساعه صاعين ولن نفكر في العواقب وليكن
ما يقعد تكتل افريقيا يعلنها مدويه لا
تفاوض سنبدا في القصف خلال ساعات قليله
نيجيريا تبدا بالضربه الاولى واحفاد
الفراعنه يتحدون مع ملوك الذهب الاسود
قائلين لسنا خارج الحسبه وبوتين يزيد من
رعب الغرب من وجهته القادمه هذه ليست اخر
صفعه لكم فمعدتي لم تمتلئ بعد ما هي الحرب
المرعبه التي تنتظرها القاره السمراء وكيف
قامت نيجيريا بالضربه الاولى فيها وهل
سيكون لمصر ودول عربيه اخرى دور فيها وكيف
غردت الامارات خارج السرب وما هي صفعه
بوتين القادمه للغرب في افريقيا لتعرف
اجابه كل تلك الاسئله تابع الفيديو
للنهايه الحرب الوشيكه افريقيا على صفيح
ساخن والعالم كله يحبس انفاسه ففرنسا التي
اجلت رعاياها من النيجر لا تزال تبقي على
قواعدها العسكريه فيها وكانها تستعد لشيء
ما حتى لا تخسر بحر اليورانيوم الذي يضيء
باريس عاصمه النور التي تواجه شبح التحول
الى عاصمه الظلام ويبدو ان الفرصه قد جاءت
لضباع الغرب على طبق من ذهب لينهش في لحم
القاره السمراء مره اخرى فبعد احتجازه طلب
رئيس النيجر محمد بازون صراحه من الغرب
التدخل العسكري في بلاده من اجل انقاضه
واعادته الى الحكم واكد لهم ان قوه فاغنار
الروسيه هي الشبح الحقيقي الذي نفذ
الانقلاب عليه وكتب على صحيفه واشنطن بوست
كانت الولايات المتحده والاتحادان
الافريقي
والمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
صارخه وواضحه في ردها يجب ان ينتهي هذا
الانقلاب ويجب على المجلس العسكري اطلاق
سراح كل من اعتقل بشكل غير قانوني وكان
يذكرهم بالتزامهم باعادته الى سده الحكم
حتى وان كان على حساب ابناء شعبه الذين
سيروحون الضحايا لاي تدخل عسكري خارجيا
لبلاده وهنا تحرك ابناء العم سام واحفاد
لواس واستخدموا منظمه ايكواس يدهم الخفيه
في افريقيا فمنذ ايام اعلنت ايكوس عن مهله
تنتهي في السادس من اغسطس الجاري للجيش
النيجيري من اجل اعاده الرئيس محمد بازون
الى الحكم وان لم يتراجع الجيش فستتدخل
المجموعه بجيوشها عسكريا في النيجر لاعاده
بازون الى الحكم بالقوه العسكريه بالطبع
ستك
مدعومه بالقواعد العسكريه الفرنسيه
والامريكيه الموجوده في المنطقه وان كان
من خلف الستار ولماذا خلف الستار من
الاساس الم يطلب الرئيس نفسه صراحه من
الغرب التدخل العسكري في بلاده السؤال
الاهم الان هل سيقطع الدب الروسي
شوكه في الحلق وكانها شوكه وضعها الدب
الروسي في حلق ابناء العم سام واحفاد لويس
فقوه ايكواس نفسها التي تعتمد عليها فرنسا
وامريكا منقسمه في داخلها بسبب بوتين ذلك
لان دولا مهمه ومؤثره في المجموعه مثل
مالي وبوركينا فاسو وغينيا قد اعلنت دعمها
لجيش النيجر ووقوفها في صف موسكو بل انهم
اعلنوها صراحه ان اي حرب على النيجر بعد
الانق تعني حربا على بلادهم ايضا ورفضوا
حتى الالتزام بالعقوبات الاقتصاديه التي
فرضتها ايكوس على النيجر ما يعني انه اذا
شنت جيوش الحرب على جيش النيجر سوف تلتفت
مجموعه من نفس التحالف لتحارب ضد التحالف
نفسه باريس واشنطن في ازمه حقيقيه لقد قطع
بوتين يدهما الخفيه في افريقيا يا الهي
اوروبا وامريكا ينشدونك الرحمه يا بوتان
ولكن ياتي رد الدب الروسي سريعا على الغرب
ما دمتم تقفون امام قطار السريع فعليكم ان
تتحملوا مسؤوليه تكسير عظامكم فماذا لو
قامت بتنفيذ تهديدها وتدخلت عسكريا في
النيجر اليوم الحرب بدات بعد تهديد مجموعه
ايكواس خرج وزير الخارجيه الروسيس معلنا
علينا التحضير لاعاده ترتيب الاوراق في
النيجر من جديد انه بوتين العنيد يتجاهل
التهديد ويضع الجميع امام الامر الواقع لم
تعد النيجر كما كانت قبل السادس والعشرين
من يوليو ومن يتهور لن يجد امامه الا فوهه
المدافع الروسيه ودون اي رحمه ولكن يبدو
ان هناك دولا لم تستمع لانذار الدب الروسي
فمنذ ايام قامت نيجيريا بالضربه الاولى ضد
النيجر بان قطعت عنها الكهرباء وفصلت خط
التوتر العالي لتعيش بذلك 70% من مساحه
النيجر في الظلام ليس هذا فحسب بل قامت
السلطات النيجيريه بتحطيم حفارات تنقيب عن
النفط تخص شركات خاصه في النيجر كانت تنقب
عن الذهب الاسود قرب الحدود بين البلدين
ويبدو ان الامر لن يقف عند حدود حرب
اقليميه او صراعات في حدود القاره السمراء
فاذا بدات الحرب المسلحه ستدعم قوه فاكنار
جيوش الدول المؤيده للدب الروسي مثل
بوركينا فاسو ومالي وغينيا في حين ان باقي
جيوش ايكواس يكونون مدعومين من الغرب واذا
تدخلت امريكا وفرنسا في الحرب بشكل صريح
فلن يكون بعيدا ان تدخل موسكو بطرسانتها
الحربيه العملاقه في الحرب وبشكل صريح
ايضا ليس هذا فقط يا عزيزي بل هناك صدمه
اخرى فمنذ ايام ذهب القائد في الحرس
الثوري الايراني اسماعيل القاني الى ليبيا
ومنها الى النيجر اي ان طهران تنوي الدخول
على خط الازمه وبالطبع سيقدمون الدعم
العسكري لحلفاء موسكو تخيل يا عزيزي حربا
تضم اربعه دول نوويه ودعني اقول لك ان
المنطقه العربيه ليست بعيده عن غبار هذا
الصراع المدمر فالقوات المسلحه النيجيريه
كانت قد تلقت تدريباتها على يد الجيش
المصري والذي كان يعمل على انهاء التواجد
منذ نحو ثلاث سنوات كما ان السعوديه وكل
دول الخليج تشترك مع النيجر ومجموعه في
مصالح اقتصاديه ضخمه ورغم ان مصر
والسعوديه واغلب الدول اعلنوا حيادهم
بخصوص انقلاب النيجر الا ان الامارات كانت
هي الدوله الوحيده التي غردت خارج السر
فقد اعلن ابناء زايد دعمهم لمجموعه الغرب
ضد جيش النيجر وانه لابد من عوده الرئيس
محمد بازون حالي في فرنسا الوثيق على راس
السلطه ولكن كيف يفكر الدب الروسي الان لا
شيء متروك للصدفه وكان بوتين لا يريد ان
يترك شيئا للصدفه او المفاجاه ارسل بوتين
مجموعه كبيره من قوه فاغنار الروسيه الى
العاصمه النيجيريه نيامي الهدف المعلن هو
تدريب قوات الجيش النيجيري بينما يرى
اخرون ان بوتين يستعد للحرب الكبرى فمن
يقترب لن يجد امامه الا صوته المرعب وحوش
فاغنار لم يقترب احد فسيخطى الدب الروسي
نحو وجهته المقبله والتي ستكون في الاغلب
دوله تشاد فاذا استطاع رجل موسكو القوي
اكمال مهامه بالسيطره على تشاد فسيكون قد
بنى حزاما روسيا على غرب افريقيا وسيتحول
هذا الحزام الى جدار ثلاثيا يستحيل على
الغرب اختراقه لتسترح القاره السمراء منه
بالغرب لثرواتها الى الابد السؤال لكم
مشاهدينا هل ترون ان انقلاب النيجر سيتحول
الى حرب عالميه كبرى تعصف بالجميع ام ان
ضباع الغرب سيتراجعون امام عنادي وجراه
الدب الروسي اخبرونا في صندوق التعليقات
[موسيقى]